it began with the forging of the great
theories
three were given to analog horror
beautiful and purest of all content
seven were given to Rick and Morty
crafted in the halls of Adult Swim
nine were given to Disney who Above All
Else desired power but there was a final
Theory forged in secret in the bowels of
Mount YouTube
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that bows to the one algorithm
that rules them all it's been a while
since we last covered the Lord of the
Rings on the channel nearly five years
in fact back then we covered the
massively popular fan theory that when
Gandalf told the fellowship too
he was literally telling the fellowship
to fly the Giant Eagles to Mordor well
it seems like the creators of Amazon's
new Lord of the Rings series The Rings
of power saw that theory and didn't
particularly care for it considering
that in like the first five minutes of
their new Lord of the Rings series The
Rings of power an eagle gets numbed on
by a giant Beast falls through a
fireball and then crashes into the
middle of a battlefield geez guys
Overkill much don't take it personally
remember it's all just a theory by the
way did you know that Amazon spent 250
million dollars just on the rights to
make the new rings of power series and
they've poured an additional 465 million
into making the first season and let me
just say when your budget budget is more
than the gross domestic product of nine
separate countries yeah your series is
gonna look great the rings of power is
gorgeous the costumes are cool the
effects are near Flawless the scripts
are meh not to say the rings of power is
bad by any means it's it's pretty good
but only pretty good is a tough review
when you're talking about one of the
most incredible fantasy series of all
time I guess money truly can't buy
happiness or scripts with forward
momentum all joking aside we gotta be
honest with ourselves this was always
gonna be an impossible uphill battle who
was really gonna win here A near perfect
screen adaptation for one of the best
longest lasting novel trilogies of all
time we're a brand new series that's
riffing on a mix of new characters
alongside some old faces whose most
exciting Adventures we already know like
I said it's fine but the Peter Jackson
movies were iconic not only did they
have themselves the biggest battles in
the most memorable moments but they were
filled with a near endless supply of
memes potatoes boil them Mash'Em stick
them in a stew man I tell you what the
meme economy boomed after the films came
out and it's been thriving ever since
practically every line from the trilogy
has been made into a meme heck a few
even turned into catchy songs
but of them all there's one that's risen
Above the Rest becoming a staple across
Reddit and Twitter for over a decade One
does not simply walk into Mordor see
this one really sticks out not only
because of the Mountain of memes that it
spawned but also because you know that's
kind of exactly what happens in the
movies The Hobbits just Waltz up Mount
Doom and Chuck the ring down into the
lava get dunked on there Boromir shows
what you know but also Sean being here
should have himself a point not only is
Mordor one of the most heavily guarded
parts of the world full of evil Orcs and
lava and giant fiery eyeballs but it's
also hundreds if not thousands of miles
away from Frodo's comfortable home in
the Shire so my theorist brain did what
my theorist brain tends to do it asked
whether you could really make the
journey to Mordor on foot like we see in
the movies was this truly a case of plot
convenience Sean Bean makes it sound
like it's an impossible task the hobbits
make it look easy so which one is right
can you simply walk into Mordor pack
your second breakfast's loyal theorists
have got a long and winding road ahead
of us to figure this out we actually
broke our data collection down into
three categories physical feasibility
lore and psychology let's start with
physical feasibility could Sam and Frodo
have actually made the journey from
hobbiton to Mordor on foot so to figure
it out we first have to look at how far
the two of them actually walked
thankfully due to the Lord of the Rings
fandom being old enough to date back to
the Triassic period in terms of online
communities we actually already have the
exact path that salmon Frodo took during
their Quest mapped out starts up here in
the Shire follows along the east Road
for a spell before going down along the
Misty Mountains and Crossing through
Moria they keep heading south through
the brown lands and dead marshes before
turning East and Crossing into Mordor
all of that is generally agreed upon
easy peasy I love it when a fandom gets
along where there's some disagreement
though is the real world distance for
all of this as you can imagine scaling a
fictional world is always going to be a
bit of a tricky subject so I figured I'd
dust off the handy dandy pixel ruler to
make a measurement for myself first off
I found an official map of Middle Earth
that included a bar scale that let me
see exactly how far 50 miles was on the
map from there I broke down the
aforementioned path into segments of
roughly 10 miles hatching it all
together and counting it all up
admittedly it's a bit of a rough
estimation but between leaving the Shire
and throwing the ring into Mount Doom
the hobbits travel approximately
1840 miles or 2961 kilometers now if
that number seems high to you it's
because it is for comparison's sake
that'd be similar to walking from Los
Angeles California to Indianapolis
Indiana or from London England to Ankara
Turkey there's a reason the whole
Adventure took three movies people
Middle Earth is Big that said we also
know that the fellowship took a great
deal of this journey by boat in the film
we see them canoeing about 360 miles
down the river anduin from lothlorian to
Amon Hen that's where Boromir gets
himself turned into a shish kebab and
Frodo says yeah nah before piecing out
plus there's also a massive portion of
the trip from weathertop to Rivendell
where Frodo's carried on Horseback by
Arwin so that's another 230mph files
that's taken care of still even if we
don't count the part of the journey
that's taken by boat or by horse the
hobbits still hiked an impressive
1245 miles or 2003 kilometers but while
it certainly sounds difficult that
doesn't necessarily mean it isn't
possible if you want a real world
comparison you can actually take a look
at the Appalachian Trail from the United
States running from Georgia to Maine
this Trek is actually a bit longer than
the full distance salmon Frodo travel
clocking in at about
2190 miles or
3524 kilometers every year thousands of
hikers attempt to through hike the trail
walk in the entire route from one end to
the other and though most of them fail
about one in four are successful it just
takes a lot of patience and Trail smarts
hikers that complete the appellation
generally do so in somewhere between
five to seven months you know what they
say slow and steady hikes the trail or
something like that and in the case of
the Appalachians yeah it's entirely true
but how does that compare to what we see
in the films how fast were Sam and Frodo
able to complete their hike well well it
isn't explicitly shown they're movies
you can cover weeks or even months of
time with cool montages of our
characters jogging across the Landscapes
of New Zealand but while the movies let
us down the novels don't according to
the novels Frodo left his home in the
Shire on September 23rd of the Year 3018
of the third age and the ring was
destroyed on March 25th of the Year
3019. given that Middle Earth uses the
same calendar as regular Earth salmon
Frodo's jumped from the Shire into
Mordor took him approximately six months
it's a pretty darn close to the seven
month average needed for the appellation
so shockingly Frodo's Journey lines up
perfectly with a similar sort of hike
that we see happening in the real world
or at least it would have had it not
been for one thing the hobbits took a
lot of long breaks we're told in the
books that The Hobbit spent
approximately two months in Rivendell
from October 23rd to December 25th and
another month January 17th to February
16th in lothlorian so instead of making
the journey in six months they actually
did it in three roughly 92 days if
you're being generous and now you start
to push the edges of believability so
now the question is whether a hobbit
could travel that far in 92 days we'll
carve off about a week's worth of travel
to account for the time that they're
spending on Horseback and sailing down
the river and win it's actually way more
than they technically need but I wanted
to be generous with our estimates so
with 85 days left to walk could a hobbit
actually do it Hobbits are much shorter
than humans so we can't just take a
human's typical walking speed thankfully
it's actually easy to calculate
someone's stride length and figure out
how fast they can travel by foot a
person's stride is typically 0.415 times
their height the maximum height of a
Hobbit is four feet meaning that a
hobbit stride length is roughly 20
inches or half a meter long on average a
moderate walking pace will usually be
about 3500 steps in an hour and though
this is starting to hit the upper bounds
of what's reasonable let's assume that
the fellowship spend about 14 hours a
day traveling so with all of that in
mind a hobbit could travel about 15
miles or 24 kilometers per day that
results in one thousand three 121 miles
or
2126 kilometers in 85 days considering
the whole Trek required a total of 1 245
miles of walking they'd have some time
to spare not a whole lot but definitely
some and that's also assuming that they
didn't hasten their Pace thanks to
traveling with experienced Rangers and
guides like Aragorn and Gollum so while
it would certainly be physically
demanding it is technically possible
more importantly we also have to
remember that the fellowship took
extended breaks to Puff their pipe weed
with elrond these pit stops actually
were essential to their success because
through hiking an entire trail of this
length isn't always healthy for the body
on average men lose up to a fifth of
their body weight between 20 and 40
pounds while they hike through the
Appalachian Trail it can be seriously
dangerous if the hiker hasn't prepared
for it and even ones who do come out on
the other side with a BMI closer to
Golems than Sams
the hobbits would have definitely faced
a similar issue we even see that Sam in
particular has lost a great deal of
weight by the time they reach more
thankfully the brakes in these Elven
settlements allowed Sam and Frodo to put
weight back on their bodies and recover
from any Trail related injuries
including a pretty nasty stab wound
would hate to be walking 14 hours a day
with that one it also gave them the
opportunity to restock on some much
needed supplies including the mystical
lembis bread which is like 4 000 protein
bars jammed into a slice of Pound Cake
one small bite is enough to fill the
stomach of a grown man how many did you
eat four this meant that they didn't
have to forage fish or hunt for every
single one of their meals which in turn
made the latter months of the Trek much
more comfortable so is it possible for
someone to literally walk from the Shire
to Mordor yeah it's feasible people
regularly do longer hikes out here in
the real world would it be easy no it
would have been exhausting and pushed
their bodies to the extreme but the
hobbits could have done it so that's a
big old shack in the physical challenge
department but that's just one step in
the journey reaching Mordor was only the
first problem the second was actually
getting in an unconscious Frodo is taken
into Mordor after being captured in the
spider shelob's Lair but true to our
premise here Sam just kind of walks in
behind him after rescuing Frodo and
starting a small Riot the hobbits put on
some armor and just March in with a
group of Orcs that has to be stretching
the limits of reality right surprisingly
no first of all Hobbits are just
canonically stealthier than other races
that's why Bilbo was chosen for the
adventure in The Hobbit so Sam's
sneaking in behind the Orcs is entirely
understandable as for the Orcs not
noticing salmon Frodo dressed up an orc
armor yeah psychologically that is more
than plausible imagine that you're an
orc and Mordor not once have you ever
thought that you're gonna see two
Hobbits in your land let alone sneaking
in and out of your fortress on their way
to kill your boss you'd be legitimately
shocked because it's likely you've never
even considered that as a possibility so
your brain isn't telling you that you're
walking alongside two Hobbits instead
it's telling you that those two Orcs
next to you are just kinda short there
are plenty of examples of something
similar happening in the real world in
1990 two men dressed as guards and stole
500 million dollars worth of art from a
museum in Boston the men just walked up
to the museum after hours they flashed a
fake badge so the security guards would
let them in and then they handcuffed
those guards and calmly explained
gentlemen this is a robbery talk about
fake it till you make it another example
this one even more fun in 2013 a German
man wearing a bootleg Bishop's outfit
sauntered into the Vatican and almost
made it into the chambers where Catholic
leaders were electing the next Pope
security only became suspicious when
they realized that his Kasich was
shorter than appropriate and that he was
wearing a black fedora in place of a
skull cap and a bright purple scarf
instead of a sash maybe the guy just
wanted to play undertale the list could
go on and on but one final example here
in 1985 a man just walked into the White
House by following the Marine Corps
Orchestra despite having no instrument
or uniform the Secret Service just
assumed that he was part of the band and
the band's leader assumed that he worked
for the White House scientifically all
of these situations were made possible
by something called Observer Bias
basically this just means that observers
don't tend to see what's there but
instead see what they expect or want to
see there sometimes all you need to get
into where you're not supposed to be is
a clipboard a ladder and the right
attitude and no one will give you a
second look so yeah psychologically the
hobbits are walking into Mordor checks
out too makes that scene in the Extended
Cut of Return of the King where Sam and
Frodo blend in with a group of orc
Warriors as they March into the black
gate a lot more reasonable finally that
leaves us with the lore something that
always bothered me about the Lord of the
Rings films is that they always seem to
portray Sauron as this all-sea being
master of evil as Saruman says his gaze
just as Cloud Shadow Earth and flesh so
how can this evil Lighthouse not see the
ring that's headed straight towards him
well Saruman might have been just a hype
man here because Sauron while powerful
is far from a God in the film's Canon
sauron's eye can see a great many things
even hundreds or thousands of miles away
from Mordor but he can't see everything
everywhere all at once he isn't
omniscient for instance the eye can't
see the hobbits that are just hiding
behind rocks near him it's a bit of a
limitation we also have to consider that
the eye couldn't find the ring while it
was in Bilbo's house or with Gollum or
when it was at the bottom of the river
this proves that he doesn't
instinctively know where it is the only
times he seems able to tell exactly
where it is instantaneously is when
someone puts it on and even then he can
only GPS locate it he can't actually see
who is in possession of it after Pippin
touches the magic ball and Sauron slides
into his DMS Gandalf is suddenly worried
that Pippin is now primary Target number
one additionally Sauron can't focus on
more than one single thing at a time
that was the entire point of the final
battle in Return of the King Aragorn
leads what remains of his army to the
gates of Mordor he whispers YOLO and
crashes directly into a giant horde Of
Orcs all as a means to distract sauron's
attention and his armies away from Sam
and Frodo giving him more of a chance to
complete their Quest so from Allure
angle to check mark there too in the end
yep Boromir had no idea what he was
talking about simply walking into Mordor
and casually tossing the ring into Mount
Doom was not only feasible it was
practically the only way for the plan to
work an eagle flying in it would be
spotted by the giant glowing eyeball
riding through the mountain pass it
would cause extra scrutiny it had to be
on foot but not only that it had to be
Hobbits see in Middle Earth Hobbits are
unique people they don't want for
anything they're simple folk living
simple lives and they're satisfied doing
only that they were created by Tolkien
to represent the every man The Humble
people that work hard and make Society
function and when even a task they're
the little guy that'll rise to the
occasion to save the world walking into
Mordor and destroying the one ring is
something in tolkien's lore that only a
hobbit could do basically everyone we
meet along the way in The Lord of the
Rings is tempted by the ring in one way
or another Gandalf outright refuses to
even touch the ring for fear that its
power would lead him to do terrible
things
this comes down to one of tolkien's core
philosophies about men that those with
unlimited power even if they're good
people with good intentions will be
tempted to misuse it but the hobbits
Hobbits aren't ambitious they don't long
for power it's something Sauron
literally never expected to happen as
stated in the opening narration of The
Fellowship of the Ring something
happened
the ring did not intend it was picked up
by the most unlikely creature
creature a Hobbit
Bilbo Baggins as a result the only way
the ring can poison them is by making
them think it's really precious
something you don't want to throw away
Gollum was content to live alone in his
cave with the ring forever but never
used it for world domination Bilbo was
the same way he just liked having it
around feeling its weight in his pocket
to them giving up the ring wasn't an
issue of losing power it was more just
losing an object that had a strong
emotional attachment to practically
watching an episode of Hoarders that's
the whole point of the story of The Lord
of the Rings as these Kings and wizards
and dark Lords play at War it's the
little guy that's doing the hardest work
work that goes unnoticed by the giant
evil eyeball that doesn't appreciate him
so yeah it was possible to simply walk
into Mordor provided that you are a
hobbit going top speed for three months
and could still find the time to fight
Orcs spiders and Phantom horse riders
simple work right the every man thinks
that I absolutely know are going to be
appreciated by Amazon in their new
series but hey why don't you head on
down below this video to click that big
red subscribe button you made it to the
end of the video which means that you
liked it and presumably you'd like all
the rest of the stuff that we do here
the longer you're subscribed the more
precious this channel will seem to you
and if you want another Lord of the
Rings Theory right now go check out the
video that I mentioned at the top where
we talk about why the fellowship didn't
just hop on the Eagles and fly the ring
to Mordor also would you like more Lord
of the Rings theories like I said we got
the rings of power also Game of Thrones
so if you want some fantasy stuff here
on the channel let me know down in the
comments below and as always remember it
was just a theory a film Theory and cut